bonsoir nouvelle édition du 7 8 l'actu
le journal de la rédaction voici les
titres de ce 17 juin la proposition du
maire d'elancourt sur le rythme scolaire
ne fait pas l'unanimité auprès des
enseignants ils viennent d'être reçus à
l'hôtel de ville par les élus qu est
long cours qui par la voix de son
premier édile ump jean michel fourgous
s'opposent à la réforme et a donc décidé
d'assurer un service minimum à la
rentrée les deux des bus mais aussi des
taxis utilisant des voies dédiées sur
autoroute d'ici 2020 le réaménagement
sera opérationnelle en ile-de-france le
président de région jean paul huchon
entend réduire ainsi de 20% les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre
invité du journal jean pierre navarro de
l'association des ailes et des hommes il
proposera dans quelques jours au grand
public et de découvrir pérou et chili à
travers ses prises de vue aériennes une
découverte en immersion grâce à un
nouveau procédé de réalité virtuelle
l'image du jour à l'image de ce 17 juin
celle du château de versailles pendant
la grande guerre l'établissement public
vient de mettre en ligne le deuxième
épisode de sa web série réalisée avec
des fonds issus de ces archives mais
aussi est de la bibliothèque nationale à
l'occasion de voir comment s'est
déroulée cette période troublée loin de
la ligne de front entre préservation du
patrimoine et accueille des soldats
blessés la web série comportera quatre
épisodes la mise en ligne se fera
jusqu'au 28 juin la date anniversaire de
la signature du traité de paix dans la
galerie des glaces
en ces temps d'économie de guerre chaque
parcelle de terre doit être exploité le
service des jardins et renforcé par des
militaires réformer ou infirme
des femmes apparaissent aussi dans les
effectifs
au printemps 1917 georges truffaut
fondateur des jardineries truffaut créer
une pépinière de plants et légumes
répartis en différents endroits du
domaine
à trianon la mise en culture est assurée
par 70 militaires indochinois les
légumes qui agrémenteront l'ordinaire
des poilus sont emballées dans
l'orangerie puis expédiés vers le front
une web série proposait donc par le
château de versailles le ton monte à
elancourt en première ligne face au
gouvernement dans la contestation de la
réforme des rythmes scolaires le maire
l'ump et jean michel fourgous fait
maintenant face à une partie des
directeurs d'écoles et des enseignants
de sa ville ces derniers se sont
regroupés ce lundi soir devant l'hôtel
de ville juste avant une rencontre avec
l'adjointe à l'éducation la réunion
devait permettre de faire le point sur
ses propositions elle des propositions
qui ne répondent pas à leurs attentes
catherine mulato claire cambier et
jonathan willeman pour les images
ils sont venus en petit nombre devant la
mairie d'elancourt ce lundi soir des
directeurs accompagnés d'enseignants
pour faire le point sur la mise en place
de la réforme scolaire à la rentrée 2014
une réunion prévue de longue date mais
qui prend ce soir là une nouvelle
dimension les enseignants ne veulent pas
des propositions de la ville faire
débuter l'école à 8h45 a rallongé d'une
demi heure la pause du midi est terminée
les cours à 16h30 on réclame tout
simplement que le l'étendent d'activités
périscolaires l'étape soient regroupées
sur trois quarts d'heures d'affilée ce
qui n'est pas le cas dans la proposition
qui a été adopté par
l'équipe municipale donc ça n'allait
gens en rien les journées des élèves et
on rajoute les trois heures du du
mercredi nous propose quelque chose qui
va vraiment à l'encontre de ce qu'on
aurait espéré dans les négociations qui
avait été entamée l'année dernière les
enseignants souhaiterait un arrêt des
cours à 16 heures au lieu de 16h30 anti
pédagogique pour le maire ump arrêté
l'école plutôt genre 15h30
15h45 vous êtes en plein pic de
vigilance puisque vous êtes depuis de
vengeance 10 10 11 heures le matin et
15h 15h30 après midi donc si vous
arrêtez les cours en plein milieu du pic
de vigilance non c'est pas conforme au
rythme scolaire
autre proposition qui soulève des
interrogations la mairie voudrait que
des enseignants prennent en charge une
partie des activités périscolaires donc
c'est vrai qu'on préférait avoir des
références table et donc des profs donc
si les profs peuvent bien entendu un
certain nombre peuvent s'impliquer dans
ces fameuses tmp à face au fameux
périscolaire en dehors de l'école ça ne
coûte plus cher bien sûr parce que les
profs coûte deux fois plus cher les
animateurs mais s'est dit nous semble
que on maîtriserait ce facteur de risque
d'avoir autant d'animateur on n'a jamais
entendu parler de cette histoire de
mettre l'été ap enfin les activités
pédagogiques par des enseignants donc on
est un petit peu surpris de l'apprendre
les directeurs d'école doivent
maintenant faire remonter toutes ces
informations auprès de leurs enseignants
un questionnaire devrait être diffusée
enseignants et parents d'élèves
maintiennent la pression ils
manifesteront ce jeudi soir devant la
mairie
jeudi soir effectivement manifestation
des parents d'élèves toujours devant
l'hôtel de ville à partir de 18 heures
aussi demandent au maire de revoir sa
copie enseignants et parents d'élèves
qui s'expliqueront ce mercredi dans le
journal à 18h en direct sur le détail de
leurs revendications et des voix pour
les taxis et pour les bus sur les
autoroutes cela pourrait fluidifier le
trafic seulement pas question de créer
de nouveaux axes ce sont les bandes
d'arrêt d'urgence voir les voies
existantes qui seraient réservés l idée
devrait en tout cas être appliquée entre
2015 et 2020 selon le président de la
région ile de france jean paul huchon
les explications d'olivier maniscalco
des voies dédiées aux bus sur les
autoroutes c'est dans le cadre du plan
de déplacement urbain que le stif et la
région ile de france ont annoncé mi juin
que les transports en commun
bénéficieront d'aménagement particulier
sur les voies rapides franciliennes
d'ici 2020 sont concernés dans le sud
des yvelines la n118 qui connaîtra des
travaux entre vélizy et le pont de
sèvres idem pour l'ex n 12 à 12 attrait
2 plaisir à boulogne en passant par
saint quentin en yvelines et poissy ces
aménagements qui varieront de 1 à 10 km
nécessiteront soit l'ouverture des
bandes d'arrêt d'urgence ou
l'utilisation du terre-plein central
soit la réservation d'une voie de bus
lors des bouchons si du côté de la
région on vise une réduction de 20 % des
gaz à effet de serre et des temps de
parcours réduits et garanties pour les
usagers du bus du côté des associations
d'automobilistes on se montre plus
circonspect les suppressions de terre
plein central et des bandes d'arrêt
d'urgence laisse apparaître des craintes
pour la sécurité des conducteurs tandis
qu'une voix supprimés aux voitures
embouteillent ray davantage la
circulation d'un montant total
prévisionnel de 65 millions d'euros en
ile de france les premiers aménagements
devraient être opérationnels dès 2015
outre les bus d'autres moyens de
transport pourrait à terme en bénéficier
tels que les taxis le covoiturage ou les
véhicules électriques
et cette idée de mettre en place des
voies spécifiques aux bus ou encore aux
taxis quand pensez-vous as une bonne
idée voici vos réponses et notre
question du jour au micro d' elodie
moines pour les vacances ça pourrait
être pas mal
s'il ya un groupe de jeunes qui veut
partir et il aura un transport moins
long donc ça pourrait être avantageux
pour eux on est en france
je pense que penser en bouteille et
qu'on voit une voix vibre ça va être dur
de ne pas y aller pour libye souhait
cette purée de papaye ça pourrait
faciliter les transports en commun
pourquoi pas si ca peut désengorger les
autres voies de circulation c'est une
bonne idée moi je pense que oui parce
que ça pourrait faciliter la circulation
dans les autoroutes je pense que c'est
une bonne idée les gens vont prendre
plus les bus et les taxis c'est cette
solution pour éviter les embouteillages
et pour
pour la circulation peut être pourquoi
pas
mais pour moi ça serait peut-être une
bonne idée outiller les taxis
l'invité de ce 17 juin à présent jean
pierre navarro secrétaire de
l'association des ailes et des hommes
une association qui depuis 2008 réunit
des amis passionnés de paramoteur ce
moyen de transport aérien composé pour
simplifier d'une voile et d'un moteur
léger bonsoir jean pierre navarro pense
que bienvenue sur ce plateau pour être
complet dans la présentation de votre
association j'ajoute que tous ces
périples que vous menez se déroule en
afrique encore en amérique du sud et à
chaque fois vous apporter aux
populations locales des fournitures
scolaires du matériel chirurgical aussi
tout cela est financé par des prises de
vues spectaculaires que vous réalisez ou
encore des opérations comme celle du 5
juillet elle en cours dont on va parler
tout d'abord le bilan de ses actions
depuis 2008 combien de pays parcourus
combien de population vous avez aidé on
a parcouru à peu près six pays vous avez
noté quelques uns il ya le burkina faso
et il y à le mali il ya le togo le bénin
la namibie et puis là dernièrement
effectivement l'argentine et le chili on
a dû aider peut-être un petit millier de
personnes ont décidé d'associer
justement santé et éducation à cette
station on est un petit groupe de parra
motoriste et on essaye de lier les deux
qui sont notre plaisir de pouvoir
voyager d'aller à la rencontre des
personnes comme vous pouvez le voir sur
les sur les vidéos
donc on fait des petites choses à notre
échelle avec des petits budgets comme
vous le disiez vendre quelques photos
voire avoir la d accompagnement de
mairie on a eu de l'aide de la mairie de
trappes des prises de vue aériennes pour
la mauricie qualité c'est ça et
également la par exemple là où je vais
faire le débriefing de notre voyage à la
pizzeria pineau de la dolce vita où nous
a aidés nous a donné 2000 euros ce qui
nous permet de faire un
dd sur un micro projets au pérou vous
avez mentionné le lieu c'est la dolce
vita sahel en course et un restaurant le
5 juillet vous allez présenter pérou
chili vous nous en dit plus sur ce
voyage comment ça s'est passé c'était
quand alors voilà ça s'est passé entre
fin c'était on est parti de 26 avril du
26 avril au 12 mai donc deux semaines
pleine nature et qu'elle on a rejoint un
ami qui était déjà là bas sur place avec
un camping-car et l'objectif c'était de
pouvoir voler le challenge était
également de pouvoir décoller à 2500
mètres d'altitude ce qui n'est pas
forcément évident peu de portance on a
réalisé des vols extraordinaire de
pouvoir voir un but de servir rêve de
gamin de pouvoir voir les lignes de
nasca elle été fait par les incas 700
ans avant jésus-christ et là vous pouvez
voir le colibri vous avez aperçu très
brièvement mais ce sont des images qui
ne se voit que
que dans comment vous préparez un tel
voyage il faut des autorisations c'est
facile finalement parce que emmener tout
le matériel sur place déjà ça devrait
être compliqué alors il faut mettre les
paramoteurs dans des valises donc là on
est entre grosses valises des grosses
valises en démonte entièrement entre
deux et trois valises chacun on le met
en pièces détachées et on a les
autorisations de pour pouvoir voyager
avec ces engins quand ils sont en pièces
détachées une fois arrivés sur place
c'est vrai ça peut être un challenge
c'est de passer les douanes et une fois
sur place on a les autorisations pour
pouvoir voler une demande à la direction
générale de l'aviation civile enfin
l'équivalent dans le pays sur laquelle
on voyage pour pouvoir voler un solide
plan de vol sur ce voyage vous avez
apporté du matériel pour les populations
locales cette fois ci on a apporté des
sous on avait identifié un projet sur
place à cusco pour pouvoir construire et
c'est ce sont des projets qui nous avait
on avait eu l'idée de ce projet là au
burkina faso parce que là-bas et cultive
la spiruline est une algue c'est un
complément alimentaire et finalement on
va amener cette technologie sur place au
pérou et j'ai en surfant par hasard sur
internet je me suis aperçu que et bien
au ces il ne cultive plus du tout la
spiruline alors que à l'époque des
aztèques il connaissait cette algue ils
ont été en fait ça a complètement
disparu donc à cusco on a identifié un
village qui va nous permettre avec 2000
euros de faire un bassin pour cultiver
de la spiruline ils ont l'eau et ils ont
le soleil tout ce qu'il faut pour voir
cultiver qui en complément alimentaire
pour les femmes et des enfants vous êtes
combien à partir à chaque fois entre
trois et dix personnes là sur ce voyage
là son père aussi nous étions trois
personnes trois personnes quels
souvenirs vous en a mais quels souvenirs
qu'est ce qui vous a le plus marqué
d'abord la rencontre avec avec les gens
vous devez pouvoir partager en fait
cette passion puisque en l'air on prend
des photos des vidéos et au sol on les
partage avec avec les personnes et c'est
ce regard parce qu'ils ne connaissent ni
le paramoteur ni ses vues aériennes et
donc c'est pouvoir partager cette
passion aussi avec avec les locaux n'y a
pas d'appréhension dit votre côté ni de
leur côté lorsque vous leur présentez
tout votre matériel quand vous expliquer
votre démarche curieusement ou pourrait
penser qu'il ya une appréhension parce
que nous sommes des étrangers parce
qu'on vient avec énormément de matériel
pas du tout en fait le fait de voler
casse une barrière c'est cette barrière
de cette première approche et ça brise
la glace tout de suite et on a un
contact immédiat avec des populations de
calais sa gelée vu ça quel que soit le
pays visités en europe en afrique ou là
en amérique du sud le 5 juillet la
population locale ici à saint quentin en
yvelines va pouvoir découvrir ce que
vous avez ramené de votre voyage là bas
et pour les amateurs de nouvelles
technologies à ce sera l'occasion de
découvrir notamment l'eau publie sous la
vè juste devant vous à la caméra c'est
cette lunette que vous avez peut-être
déjà aperçu dans de nombreux reportages
parce que c'est très à la mode en ce
moment ce sont des lunettes qui
permettent une immersion totale dans
l'image on l'aimait et c'est comme si on
y était comment ça marche alors en fait
ce sont des lunettes dans lesquelles il
ya deux lentilles et sur l'ordinateur ou
la console l'image se sépare en deux et
en fait on a ici l'image en stéréo
directement dans les yeux c'est vrai
immersion totale et là c'est la première
version la deuxième saut version sort en
juillet août de cette année c'est un kit
de développement ça c'est pas encore des
produits qui sont commercialisés quoi
qu'il en soit en fait le fait est que
l'allée des vidéos que j'ai pu faire en
360 degrés grâce à des esgaulx pro donc
en très haute résolution 6 go propos
réalisé une vidéo en 360 degrés on va
pouvoir le voir directement avec avec
cet appareil donc l'amateur de
sensations avec le paramoteur vous venez
en aide aux populations et amateurs de
nouvelles technologies aussi comment
vous êtes procuré ce modèle très bonne
question en fait des treuils de la
société avez-vous dérobés par exemple
d'une société avec des développeurs
travaillent chez intel donc on est au
fait des nouvelles technologies j'ai
demandé à un collègue s'il avait
l'oculus il me dit oui j'ai demandé si
j'en viens à créer ça a été le cas et
j'ai testé ça directement sur un
logiciel qui est compatible avec les
lunettes oculus magie c'est vraiment la
possibilité de découvrir comme si vous
étiez au pérou et au chili le 5 juillet
vous avez un petit ordinateur devant
vous parce que c'est pour peut-être
montré si on peut apercevoir sur la
caméra les vidéos en fait lorsque vous
bougez la vidéo ou lorsque vous êtes en
posant comme une photo dans bouge dans
l'image voilà tout simplement et là en
fait la vidéo elle bouge donc là en très
haute résolution avec les lunettes
oculus en bougeant la tête vous allez
pouvoir bouger à l'intérieur de la vidéo
ayant et ce en 360 degrés donc dans
toutes les directions partout vous allez
pouvoir vivre comme si vous y étiez au
dessus des lignes de nasca mine de
lithium ou la plus haute dune du monde
est à découvrir le 5 juillet prochain
voyage vous êtes déjà en préparation oui
on y pense fort l'afrique ont slogan da
ce sera sur un voyage encore pour venir
en aide aux populations là vous avez
identifié ce que vous allez faire encore
c'est souvent soit au dernier moment où
soit directement sur place pour être
plus proche en fait des besoins au
moment où
et si les gens veulent venir en aide
aussi pour mener ses projets il ya un
site internet la possibilité de se
procurer certaines de vos photos par
exemple alors le 5 je vendrai quelques
photos qui sont développés
sur dix bons l'occurrence sur du métal
voilà c'est ça être entre 50 et 80 euros
on ne vend pas cher c'est des grands
formats 50 par 70 cm sinon on a un site
internet des ailes et des hommes point
org le site qui s'est affichée merci
jean pierre navarro merci l'onu pour en
savoir plus sur cette association le
site internet et qui s'est affichée et
puis le 5 juillet rendez-vous à
elancourt dans cette dans ce restaurant
7,7 pizza arrière à tout chez vite voilà
merci à vous le mois de juin est
traditionnellement celui des portes
ouvertes dans les casernes de pompiers
du département des yvelines les
professionnels partagent leurs métiers à
travers des ateliers des démonstrations
le week-end dernier c'était au tour du
centre de secours de montigny le
bretonneux plusieurs thématiques pour
les visiteurs venus le plus souvent en
famille incendie secours routier gestes
qui sauvent l'objectif est double se
rapprocher du public mais aussi susciter
des vocations les bénévoles représentent
80% des effectifs ils peuvent débuter
très jeunes voici quelques réactions de
peut-être future recrue recueillis par
david charpentier
je pense que c'est un beau métier que
tout le monde aime bien les pompiers
parce que ben on a souvent besoin d'eux
donc c'est intéressant de voir leurs
casernes et comment ils travaillent je
suis venu c'est essentiel pour mon fils
qui est passionné à des gardes
frontières bien évidemment est-ce que tu
montes dans un camion oui c'était
comment
bien
c'est impressionne le plus c'est la
combinaison en fait c'est trop lourd la
tête ou le reader est aussi grave
florent te fait ajouter encore fera
mégalo on s'est entraîné
on a éteint des feux menacent talons
mais on a marché sur des poutres
c'est bien aimé son travail il aurait
poussé veux tu veux te pompiers oui
la ferme de thiverval grignon près de
plaisir un site qui appartient à l'école
d'ingénieurs agro paris tech qui possède
cinq cent cinquante brebis une laiterie
450 hectares de cultures mais aussi un
troupeau de 160 vaches lors des portes
ouvertes proposées au public voici
quelques jours nous avons voulu en
savoir plus sur cet élevage si vous
n'aviez pas l'occasion d'être présent
sur place le reportage de catherine
mulato et de david charpentier
il ose à peine poser son doigt sur le
pis de la vache et pourtant il ne risque
pas de lui faire mal la vache est fausse
mais le procédé identique à la réalité
une animation à la ferme agricole de
thiverval grignon pour faire comme des
vraies vaches et il faut que quartier
mais pour voir les vraies vaches il faut
se rendre à les tables ici la traite
n'est plus mécanique depuis longtemps
mais automatisé par une vache et traite
de tous les jours deux fois par jour
donc il ya 12 heures d'intervalle entre
chaque traite ici en moyenne une vache
produit entre entre 30 et 40 litres par
jour et comment faire pour obtenir du
bon lait alexandre la solution faut bien
l'alimenter bien à nourrir et que
quel est un bon confort de couchage donc
ici à grignon il ya deux sortes de
couchage en logettes est sûre sur de la
paille la ferme de thiverval grignon un
univers très rurale à deux pas de la vie
citadine on compte pas moins de 160
bêtes pour une production annuelle d'un
million et demi de litres de lait
trappe plaisir chaque week-end de juin
est marqué par une nouvelle fête de la
ville à saint cyr l'école le week-end
dernier le thème du far west a été
retenue pour fédérer associations et
population la ville qui a aussi proposé
un spectacle de rodéo les images de ce
rendez-vous un aperçu de l'ambiance avec
mathilde de kpn et jonathan vilma nil
étaient jusqu'à dix mille personnes
présentes sur place st cyr a changé de
décor après avoir décliné l'outre-mer le
moyen-âge et le cirque l'ambiance du far
west a envahi la commune chapeaux
foulards et santiags habillée de la tête
au pied certains n'ont pas hésité à
jouer le jeu dont le maire de la commune
bernard de bain déguisé en grand chef
indien je les appelais le grand chef des
comanches m'a dit non non non non non
non directeur de la communication vous
n'avez rien compris vous serez au pilori
demain je suis le grand chef navarro il
s'amuse beaucoup c'est vraiment à chaque
fois ça c'est un vrai plaisir l'année
dernière j'avais pu lui mettre un petit
tigre on dans les bras et voilà c'est un
vrai plaisir de voir un conseil
municipal et le maire au tour qui arrive
à tout simplement à s'amuser à être avec
les assyriens pour animer le village
western la mairie a fait appel à des
associations qui retrace le far west du
19e siècle mais aussi des comédiens et
de nombreux artistes venus faire le show
je fais de la coupe de fouet donc je
vous avais vu j'ai coupé déroger essayé
de couper le papier mais qui tourne mais
avec le vent c'est pas facile
aujourd'hui
ensuite faire la claque et en même temps
faire un peu un numéro d'acrobatie pour
essayer de faire un numéro plus complet
possible et montrer tout ce qu'on peut
quoi ça avec un fouet et un cheval sur
ce thème western la cascade de la
voltige et on se fait plaisir les vraies
vedettes de cette journée ont été les
chevaux et les puissants taureau un show
à l'américaine de quoi plaire au public
c'était très impressionnant c'était
j'étais bien on n'en voit pas souvent
par ici donc c'était une bonne idée et
puis on en envoie parfois à la télé mais
mais en vrai c'est quand même quelque
chose ah c'était super tu considères
bien
les taureaux côté impressionnant pas mal
tout à fait professionnel quand même on
voit que ce sont des gens qui font
partie du milieu la journée de samedi
s'est poursuivie dimanche au cinéma les
yeux d'elsa avec au programme la
projection de quatre films 100% western
et le thème de l'année prochaine sera à
plus local un pou français les villages
gaulois a priori petit voyage dont le
petit voyage dans le temps pour terminer
à présent ce journal 80 voitures
centenaire regroupés devant le château
de rambouillet pour la troisième édition
du paris rambouillet ce week end ali qui
offre une autre vie au mythe de
l'asphalt d'avant-guerre anthony rech et
jonathan vilma
elle brille le bruit de leurs moteurs
ancestrale verse à nouveau les amoureux
de mécanique
pourtant pour la plupart de ces
véhicules leurs propriétaires les ont
bichonné pendant des jours des mois pour
qu'il puisse à nouveau des vallées
l'asphalt entre joël et sa renault eu
qu'à l'histoire d'amour dure depuis cinq
ans fabriqué en 1914 ce bicylindre sans
électricité doit être démarrer à la
manivelle
je peux même presque dire qu'elle est
plus belle que tu appelles sont sortis
des usines parce que en particulier les
peintures des peintures à l'époque il ne
connaissait pas le parce que le pistolet
donc les voitures étaient pas au pinceau
et elle n'était pas aussi brillante que
vous les voyez maintenant mais bon
on se fait plaisir avec les années les
progrès technologiques certains outils
ont disparu et il faut parfois les re
créer soi même une fois rénové et même
par dose de quelques centaines de
kilomètres par an s'asseoir au volant de
ces voitures de musées ne s'improvise
pas on retrouve le plaisir de conduire
personnellement c'est le plaisir de
conduire une voiture moderne on fait
plus attention à ce qu'on fait parce que
tous à l'autoradio est allé voiture
boîte automatique maj à tout va ce bien
là accélérateur au volant donc
fera débrayages mais accélérateur au
volant en l'espace d'un siècle comme
cette le zèbre de 1909
la plupart de ces mythes du bitume on
tue plusieurs vies une première sur la
route une deuxième dans les fermes ou
les châteaux pour tracter ou transporter
des marchandises et quant à la chance
d'avoir subsister on les récupère nous
pour leur donner leurs 3e et là on
espère que c'est pour l'éternité parce
que plus rien leur arriver maintenant
rénover cette renault au cas est évalué
à 40 mille euros mais pour l'instant
désolé pour les amateurs elle n'est pas
à vendre
en fin de journal pour ce 17 juin demain
mercredi vous retrouverez à catherine
cela tôt dès 18 heures je vous donne
rendez vous ce soir ce mardi soir pour
une nouvelle édition du 7 8 c'politique
18h30 19h30 et 23 heures il sera
question des jeunes udi de leur avenir à
peine plus d'un an après leur création
et de cette centaine de députés
socialistes qui s'opposent au
gouvernement avec le député des yvelines
jean philippe mallet très bonne soirée